struggle through the Sixers first nine  games to start the season drunk we  should issue the Pistons as we begin the  second Andre Drummond is back in your  picture he's going to try to take on and  be Wow  did he actually expect that to go in man  personal basketball player right there  that was terrible that was worse than  the three he took earlier  Serena winters Halle Hampton Abbie marks  him off tonight and that time and be  blocking the attempt by Drummond who  looks at helplessly at the official in  his mind that everything is going to be  in the paint going to the rim  well Drummond out totally off his game  he's scoreless he's got one rebound and  he will trudge now to the bench